I don't have nor I lost
acampadentro just put me the benefits there in the projected
so that death is going Willem
National de Galicia on the other side there she
even though he knows then if in the clinics
a kind of fact is this is the profiles we
work in Wonderland  was super strong of the
project plan Drake the lord of his
cold air integrate and your neighbors World
food Day Card Slots and super Friends
today with the escape game let your
child to you guys or not this time to go
to track The day-to-  day Life and even
though we come from a land is your Land
and End of the first thing You Only
enter into you mommy to questions to get
a Free to this question would take about
love
e é bom é uma guerra dos men has a photo of
her hair  and that little ones over
there at that Teca Ltd, the person says what
was between Igor enter by the numbers
If you need something
I want it in Portuguese Of course
it has to stay Day After Senhor
Antônio and Fernanda Janeiro in
and see what it is  having to go to
Camila's house and drive from the neighbors hear
your name is an
the only sound that has to have a quiet
invitation dressed plagramme is
Andthen
the beautiful cattle and
the songs of ever I I think we are very
cold night forever and one spirit  take
good care Services which were closed on
That's it, sell flowers neybers
ceramiche you are your Light and Heavy
neighbor here and here Wants this book
deals and We wish you a place orders on
food chain and for some reason this one
it is a very  Sweet Dog Pet bike
microphone and
Ah,
André lá Box sex work on the land to
speak English and be checking back often
Higher The Gift am the state of mind of
dental floss understand more about life
with
you João Soares Dias Fernanda Antônio
Marques
and  it's 70 years 6473 it's very complicated it's 73 it
did this month the day before yesterday thank you
I got in early since
the word o pens was born so that's how I'm
raised here so na yes here I was born
here still today they call me Tomé every
arr  ancada
and anywhere to that place
Santa comba tondela excellent knows
I'm Antonio Marcos but Tomé every
sprint that's why I still know it
today because the MEC the sprint wants to
burst it's called sprint
Yes, I've been Immigrants from Latin
America to Venezuela and Europe  Switzerland and
Lisbon only go nowhere oh Lisbon is 14
years old because I was in Venezuela I
was in the United States
and if it's good to live here I think I
give my land ok I like everything is
my land but I liked it more than
this property was where I was born
where I was raised from here to the
EA school for the doctrine in the old days and
here was a family it was a village
this here was an authentic and
prevailing population everywhere it was
wonderful and it still is wonderful today
a recipe for a very light belt
for there
and not because not because I'm not poultry
And then I don't know if I would like it I've never been
used to it I think it's better if
I don't like the city because I don't  I saw
Vitória there but if you will be able to
show but that I did not go to the City it was
very agitated it was in your breathing the
fresh air in São João at ease it was not
easy to fix set in another country that
environment in another country of another evolution
this  here it was not easy for me
environment gun later i saw that really
here it was tranquility it was a dream to
drink the birds in the nest here
knowing all this is wonderful different from the
city even today i don't know you come
here with this virus we are crossing is
at us  we feel better the part of these
Of these suddenly all this so
I am pleased to have it is this land
and Bible in peace game joy and a
happy is it
is very little because I have little
schooling but I have someone from the
elderly family that we had to work with the
internet  with my son to Luxembourg
I don't don't have a phone call I don't already
have one give up I like to walk around the
property
and get things off my mind
and if I've met a lot of people to  or here
I've known this as the apple orchard
I've known this by
tenants were here living
EA living here and cultivating and
all the land here that
their survival survived several couples
and so far Bible and servant and we played
here all without  work we are going to plant
we are here always I am here it
was a whole family is laughing it was a
family everything correct the lands they
were all cousins in everything and they lived I knew that this
as the way my father left here and the o
hers sent him away I don't
want her today  people money aside this
but but it was nothing we already had the
right This here quite enough
every time I come here and analyze
what it used to be I want it
land for land property property
and feel sad what this was that it
is being  because he was raised here in the
midst of nature and living in the midst of
nature is wonderful that I
miss the old times but still the
earth still lives only that it ends n  no one
to live with her takes the key off it's not
good You're still good I'm glad I'm
happy with Gravel you
good and that you are really a good people and
that we arrived here and Repairs done
is Buenos días good afternoons good morning good
afternoon is good is  very good is very good
Hello, everything is good here the only thing
that is wrong with me now is the abandonment
that the vegetation took over all of this
because it was the lack of abandonment of the
land by the previous owners no no no
no no at all  it's just always a
good memory
I haven't had problems with anyone
enemy We also everywhere even though
we often sleep we hurt anyone
but there is always that person who is
super ambitious to sunbathe just to
catch them and the others have not said anything I
don't  I am this ambition and when others
live well I also live well it
's good I like spring more I like
summer
better The best thing is that it's good people come
to the shade ok I'll honestly say I
like winter better  and i will explain
why when i was in venezuela the heat
there which is a tropical country is not easy in
america we have working days when we
cannot work i have to go home
the heat is unbearable and for
better support in winter than in summer  the
sign here in our Portugal is one it's a
more or less good climate even in the summer it's
so scorching But I prefer more or
less winter I'll give a paper
and the rain is necessary because the water
people
would survive if you weren't for  water we didn't
survive, neither we nor the animals
if you don't like it when so much rain falls
rain is good at the time it is needed the
rain is good why don't we ask
this summer the rain a blessing from
God the rain is wonderful the rain is
same blessing If we don't really analyze
how the rain comes that's where
the rain is ready to fall it's wonderful to
enjoy the rain he thought the
window rain a blessing comes to the earth
let's do anything without rain I can I can
fill  forward come to water me love
this rain
and it was in 2005 and 2017 each stanza to us
i lost all the forest i had
i lost everything i had big plantations
of several trees i lost everything and
now ready try to
get things put  more or less
but the things they used to have never go away
and the fire was terrible it was bad for
everyone and but for me or not ready your
sea gave the number it gave a lot it's not for
who it was it gave the causes and everything got worse
it's not for me it was terrible although the
house tractors dogs bit my
share of vines and olive
trees and fruit trees on the properties everything burned
everything sheds up there that in my
opinion it gave everything the test make a few we stayed
thank god we stayed  so
what we're going to do was a
terrible thing, just because there's no
explanation and I'm glad and I'm glad
it was at night, it brought a lot of
people died because of everything I went running around the
properties when my eyes burn What
q  what is burning and in Via there may
be something to hug my saw he
can go
I tried hard
Yes it is very good it is very good
and we people who
do this development in the country we
like it very much thank you  but now
I'm not recording you guys have it here
until it's so good it's not even ohsawa Lisa
take my gloves it's crazy I like it
the more the better we're not
here alone later we die don't
be alone like this I'm staying with
others
Hello my  pocket drawings you better
then they are still young to
produce a lot there since they had to test
so I don't like us after that the
nice people this is good for everyone right I like it
without it's with great pleasure I really like
that I come here let's go here Someone
where  I enjoyed it in the past Nicole
wants you to enjoy it now it's not fruit it
's not going to be easy now it's not that you get in
here because it used to be very
cultivated it was all beautiful everything shouldn't
be it was here Mimosa  I didn't know any of
that, right now it is but I have
to find a place so it's very good
I'm very satisfied it's good
150 years ago I'm bought it was over
80 years old Google She's my mother she
must be 30 or so  40 Because we are 113
up and one to make a new bike
to choose where I want and I would take it
off but I don't do it for you it's just for
that it's not a great specialty But
it's delicious isn't it a great
reality I think it's better the mother
Sandra being the job that is going up is
very heavy super Nice people and look
forward to many more you need your
language better work on both slurry if
you wanna see all the things we make for
returning to your playlist with Lack of
the one sweep train  for directly with
which we can go back to the Snipers what
I love romance have suggestions
Hi how was it TV support can end up
from Calma knows Connect Parts and it's
strong there, so be careful Adilson hole in
what year